[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to build end-to-end solutions
with vertex ai my name is sarah robinson
i'm a developer advocate on the google
cloud team
focused on machine learning and you can
find me on twitter at s rob tweets
i'm going to be talking about vertex ai
which is new it was just announced
earlier today
so i'll start by giving you an overview
of what vertex ai is
then i'll talk about how you can use
vertex ai tools to streamline your
machine learning
model development process we'll look at
productionizing ml workflows with
pipelines and finally we'll end on some
tools you can use to monitor your
deployed machine learning models
so to start what is vertex vertex is a
managed machine learning platform
that can help practitioners accelerate
their experiments and
deploy machine learning models but how
does this fit into
a typical application development
workflow so vertex ai will sit at your
application back end
giving you all the tools you need to
build train and deploy
machine learning models your application
logic will talk to these deployed models
getting predictions
and surfacing those predictions to end
users those end users could be
in an offline on-device use case or they
could be desktop
or mobile clients and what's all
included in vertex
so these are all the products that are
part of vertex ai as i mentioned they
can take you through
your entire machine learning workflow
from gathering data
to deploying and monitoring your models
and i'm going to be talking about a few
of these products
in this talk today i'll be highlighting
tools that focus on these parts of a
machine learning process so we'll look
at tools to help you
gather your data train your model then
we'll go to how to deploy models to
endpoints
we'll look at streamlining workflows
with pipelines and finally we'll look at
some monitoring tools
just a quick note that vertex ai
supports both ui based and code based
model development
while i'll be focusing mostly on the ui
in this session
note that all of the functionality i'll
be covering has equivalent
sdk methods so you can implement
everything i'm showing programmatically
now we're going to look at how you can
use vertex ai to streamline your model
development
and when i'm working with customers and
external users the first question i'll
typically ask
is do you have your own training data if
the answer is no
we have a set of pre-trained apis that
give you access to
machine learning models for common tasks
like analyzing images and analyzing text
all you need to do is send a simple rest
api request
for the duration of this presentation
i'm going to focus on the right side of
this flowchart
i'm going to assume that you do have
custom data available and you want to
use that custom data
to train a machine learning model custom
to your prediction task
so if that's the case the next question
to ask is are you writing this model
code yourself
and whether the answer is yes or no we
have tools
to help you train your models on vertex
ai let's take a look
so how does model development work in
vertex ai i've split this into three
steps
gathering your data then choosing the
training method you'll be using and then
finally
deploying your model whether you're
deploying it offline on device
to an endpoint for online serving or
running batch predictions
let's start with gathering data and for
this we have a product called manage
data sets
with managed data sets you upload your
data first you choose the type
of data you'll be working with and then
from there you'll choose the prediction
task that you'll be solving
if your data doesn't fit into any of
these use cases don't worry at all you
can still
train and deploy your models with vertex
ai
once you've got your data ready the next
step is to choose your training method
one option for this is automl automl
lets you train
custom machine learning models without
requiring you to write any machine
learning code of your own
vertex ai will handle finding the
optimal model architecture for your
prediction task and giving you access to
state-of-the-art machine learning models
once your model is trained
you get access to detailed model
evaluation metrics
and you also get feature attributions
which are powered by google cloud's
explainable ai
feature attributions tell you which
features in your model signaled your
model's predictions the most
this helps you get a little bit more
insight into how your model is
performing under the hood
the other option for training your
models is to use custom training
with custom training you can train
models using a framework of your choice
and you can either use one of the
pre-built containers we have available
or package your model training code as a
docker container
and use the custom container option for
training with either of these
custom training lets you run distributed
training jobs and also gives you access
to
accelerate your training with gpus using
custom training you can also take
advantage of hyper parameter tuning
to run multiple trials of your training
jobs in parallel
to find the optimal hyper parameters for
your task
so once you've got a trained model
you'll likely want to deploy it to an
endpoint
and whether you've trained your model
with automl or with your own custom
model code
all endpoints in vertex ai show up in
the same place in your console and are
accessible
via the same api you can split your
traffic between models once you've
deployed them to an endpoint so this is
really useful if you want to do
something like a b
testing or maybe you want to roll out a
new model update
incrementally to some of your users you
can also customize the machine type
where your model is deployed so i've
talked about how you can go
from raw data to deployed model but in a
real world scenario
there will be many teams solving a lot
of different prediction tasks
across your organization and we need a
way to manage this process for that
we'll use the practice of ml ops
so what is mlaps mlops is a practice
that defines processes to make your
machine learning development
more reliable and productive it can help
you standardize your machine learning
systems
so that multiple teams and people across
your organization can reproduce
those systems rapidly and reliably
vertex ai has a variety of tools to help
with mlaps they're highlighted here in
blue
and i'm going to go into a few of them
in this presentation
before i do that let's look quickly at
how mlaps fits into a typical
application development workflow
so once you have a deployed model you
have users generating
new predictions on that model you want
to make sure that your model is still
performing
as you'd expect and then you may want to
feed those new predictions
into your model train a new version of
your model redeploy it and start this
process again
the first ml ops product they'll
introduce is vertex feature store
vertex feature store is a centralized
repository of feature data
which means that your feature
engineering work can be shared across
teams
so let's take a look at what problem
this solves and to do this let's imagine
that you have
one team in your organization that's
building a model to predict whether or
not somebody's going to return an item
that they've purchased
now let's say one of the features that
is input to this model
is a windowed aggregation of purchase
data
now imagine that you have another team
in your organization that's solving an
entirely different task
but they're also computing this windowed
aggregation
these two teams aren't talking to each
other and there's no centralized
repository for your feature data
they're going to be wasting time and
effort by computing the same feature
twice
so this is one of the problems that's
solved by feature store
feature featurestar also lets you serve
your machine learning features at scale
with low latency
and finally it alleviates the problem of
training serving sku
which happens when the way that you
compute features at training differs
from how you're doing it at serving time
with vertex feature store you only
compute your feature values once and
then you reuse them
for training and serving feature store
also lets you track
and monitor for drift and other quality
issues
next we'll look at how you can
productionize your machine learning
workflows with pipelines
before i dive in a quick note that a
deployed machine learning model is only
the beginning of your ml
process once your model is deployed you
want to make sure to avoid things like
concept or model drift
which can happen when the environment
around your model changes
and pipelines can help automate this
retraining workflow
we believe that pipelines are the
backbone of production machine learning
systems
and by pipelines we mean your end-to-end
machine learning workflow
broken up into distinct steps for each
task along the way and these steps are
also referred to as components
to build pipelines we're introducing
vertex pipelines which is new today
vertex pipelines is a managed service
that lets you build pipelines with
familiar
open source pipeline frameworks like
tensorflow extended
tfx or kubeflow pipelines it's automated
scalable and cost effective so you pay
only for what you use
what we're looking at here is a pipeline
graph and
in the vertex pipelines console you can
inspect each individual step of your
pipeline
each step of the pipeline will generate
an associated artifact
that's fed into the next step all these
artifacts are stored in a central
storage location
and right in the console you can click
into individual steps
see the associated artifacts that were
generated from that step and you can
also
track these artifacts that were
generated across separate pipeline runs
with vertex pipelines you can also add
conditional logic to your pipeline
so let's say that you only want to
redeploy a model
if that model's accuracy is above a
certain threshold so you can add logic
like that or whatever type of logic
you'd like
to your pipeline you can also store
metadata for every artifact
that's produced by the pipeline and as i
mentioned before you can track artifacts
across your machine learning workflows
finally we'll look at how you can use
vertex ai to monitor your deployed
models
first an important distinction between
mlaps and devops
so unlike with traditional programming
your model may not be performing as you
would expect it to
even if that prediction code still works
the environment
around your model may have changed in
such a way that it's not performing
predictions
correctly so this is known as drift and
we need a way to continuously monitor
our models
to catch when this happens for that
we're introducing
vertex model monitoring which is new
today
with model monitoring you can
automatically alert your data scientists
and ml engineers
when model performance changes to do
this you create a monitoring job and
within that job
you define an objective once your job is
kicked off
you'll be alerted whenever performance
goes below a certain threshold
you can use model monitoring to detect
things like drift and training serving
sku
so rather than manually checking to make
sure your model is still performing
correctly
this provides confidence in model
reliability because you'll be alerted
anytime something changes i covered a
lot of different products in this
presentation so just to recap
i showed how you can use vertex ai
throughout your machine learning
workflow
we started by looking at how you can use
vertex to gather data
build and train your models then we
looked at how you can scalably deploy
your models to endpoints
then we talked about how you can
automate your machine learning workflows
with pipelines and finally we looked at
tools for
monitoring your machine learning models
to make sure they're still performing as
expected
and retraining them if they are not
thanks for watching i hope you enjoy the
rest of the sessions at google i o
and to get started with vertex ai and
dive right into the vertex console
head over to cloud.google.com vertex
dash ai finally we have a couple of
events coming up where you can learn
more and get hands-on with
vertex ai the first is at the google
cloud data summit on may 26th
and the second is at the google cloud ml
practitioner summit on june 10th
to register head over to the link on the
slide
thanks for watching
[Music]